good morning everybody uh like to
welcome everybody to House Education
today what we have on the dock is we
have one bill that we're going to be
hearing first that's 218 and I see
Senator Fenton here from uh King uh
welcome and uh following that we're
going to go into a brief caucus because
we have some bills coming up to exec
today
and so we will caucus immediately
following the hearing and then come back
I can tell you on 272 the way we're
going to operate and function on that
there's going to be one person from each
party speaking on behalf of that here at
the executive session
and then we're going to go ahead and
move into the vote
so with that
um I'd like to go and open up this
hearing on 218 and welcome center Fenton
I haven't seen you in a long time it's
thank you
thank you Mr chair and Ladies and
Gentlemen of the committee for the
record I am Senator Donovan Fenton I
represent district 10 which is a lot of
town so I'm not going to say them all
for you guys
I am here today to talk to you about
Senate Bill 218 establishing an early
educator professional development Grant
218 aims to address the retention of our
teachers
as we all know teachers are integral
part of every child's life which is why
we should enable our state with every
tool possible to ensure our children
have the best and brightest teaching
them in the classroom this bill
establishes an early educator
professional Grant this grant aims to
increase teacher retention increase
teacher support efforts and increase the
likelihood of success for New
Hampshire's Educators by incentivizing
teachers to stay in this field
this bill is based on another
recommendation from the commission to
study our teacher shortage so this is
not necessarily a new idea
we know the first couple of years of a
new Educator's career are crucial to
Foster their drive to make teaching a
lifelong career too often lately we are
seeing teachers enter the field and
leave it a year or two later which is
why we need to provide school districts
with the resources to support and Mentor
new teachers I hope you will join me in
supporting 218 and help our teachers
find a home in New Hampshire teaching
where they feel supported and valued and
with that I will take any questions
thank you very much Senator are there
any questions of Senator Fenton yes
represent luno and then represent Myler
not represent Miler thank you Mr chair
and thank you senator for bringing this
before us today as you know
we've had this uh teacher shortage uh uh
work group uh working on this and I
think your bill basically speaks to a
major piece of this as it relates to
retention and I appreciate you bringing
this forward to us thank you very much
yeah absolutely I um it's really about
teachers who went to the field and we're
seeing them leave a year or maybe two
years later and this will really help
support them in that field and hopefully
retain them representative luno
thank you very much Mr chair and thank
you very much senator for for bringing
this forward so um I do notice that that
um there's a fiscal note on this bill
but it says uh they were unable to
provide as introduced at the at the time
in your estimate what would the fiscal
cost be of that's a great question I
think there's people behind me that
could probably answer it a little better
than me okay well just as a follow-up on
on that so so it does talk about
um a grant
um uh being a half million dollar an
annual appropriation five hundred
thousand dollars
um uh is that how does that compare with
with a bill that's being heard in Senate
education right now in terms of use of
State uh State dollars and the impact uh
it could have on families and Workforce
so thank you for the question I will
compare it to another bill
um however this bill really is one of
the main pillars to help our Educators
and retain them I think that's what
really comes I know I keep saying that
word retain but that's really what it
keeps coming back to is that
um we're losing teachers whether that's
be to a different industry or another
state that pays more I think when a
teacher feels valued in their District
or in their school and their support and
um that truly goes a long way in keeping
that individual in that school
I do have one question for you Senator
yes sir um
within the bill itself it's this is a
grant for five hundred thousand dollars
uh when I looked at the fiscal note and
with doe there's apparently they're
looking for like a 0.3 full-time
equivalent when I try to do some rough
modern mathematics came out with about
twenty five thousand dollars uh is it
possible that that 25 Grand could come
out of the five hundred thousand yeah
absolutely thank you Mr chair for the
question absolutely and also we're
talking about point three if I
understand it correctly 0.3 working you
know how how much uh work is that
individual going to do uh there's
nothing in here that dictates to higher
individual to run this program or
anything like that
um 0.3 is pretty small number uh so I
think it's easy enough to
um maybe spread the job between two
people maybe 0.5 and you know
yeah further questions from the
committee representative cascaden thank
you Mr chair and thank you on behalf of
teachers senator
questions one is what is your intent of
early educator are you talking about
preschool K and how how high up the
grades and my second question is on line
six
um whether you would consider uh
changing the word and to or
and that would make
um
that would provide options
um I've found that implementing mentors
um can be very valuable
so if they could Orient support or
Mentor Educators and what what is the
intent of early educator absolutely
thank you for the the questions the
intent of early is early in their career
not in terms of
the age group they're teaching we're
talking about an individual that has
been in the uh a teacher that's been
within the first three years of the
career in education line set okay thank
you uh because that's who we're really
targeting is these new Educators who uh
want to feel welcomed want to feel
supported in terms of your suggestion
I'll leave that up to you find
individuals here in the house education
committee I think you all know what
you're doing so
point to that
thank you further questions from the
committee
yes representative dry
thank you
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um I was looking at the comments from
the Senate hearing and uh was talking
about
um virtual mentoring for Rural Educators
in a program from that was that still
included in this
um I'm not sure if that individual is
here who testified on that subject um
the way I understood it was that the
state outsources a rural educator
program to
do something like Colorado that has a
very large fiscal note that we're doing
and this could somewhat take place of
that or maybe spend less money going out
of state and actually spending more
money locally
if that answer your question yeah I was
just wondering if there was a quote here
about maybe spending it locally and
wonder if they've been progress on that
issue
if this bill passes there'll be progress
any further questions of the senator
thank you very much thank you guys have
a good day
do you have a cool heart coming with you
Mr chairman member it's a house
education committee for the record my
name is Megan Tuttle I'm president for
Nea New Hampshire representing 17 000
Educators across the state with me I
have Irv Richardson who is our
coordinator for public education and
school support and so we're going to
testify together if that's okay
as you're aware Senator defense said
we're facing a crisis in education this
isn't anything new we have you know an
educator shortage the committee that was
set up did come out with some ideas and
I believe this was one of them
we do want to say though we don't really
think we have an educator shortage for
the most part
um we we don't have a shortage of
potential Educators but we do have a
shortage of Educators coming into the
profession so the people are there but
we need to come up with ways to attract
them and to retain them and this can go
back as far as high school getting that
pipeline from high school into the
profession into the pre-service programs
that we have in colleges and then also
into you know keeping them in New
Hampshire
um so I feel the line of sight
um so the talents out there but you know
not having support for this Talent is
going to be a hindrance to attracting
entertaining that Talent historically I
think we've said this before and I'm
sure you've heard if Educators or
teachers are going to leave the
profession they're going to leave within
the first five years this bill would
allow that mentoring to really help and
booster it so that they're not leaving
within the first five they feel
supported
um you know as the professionals that
they are they would help require local
professional development master plans to
articulate professional learning goals
and have that mentoring Early Education
leaders this legislation would also
provide matching grants to local school
districts that use their local funds to
help fulfill these sort of plans this is
kind of a multi-pronged effort to
attract and retain those teachers I like
to think of it as a three-legged soul
and so when I was teaching and I had
open house in the classroom I would talk
to the parents about education really is
a three-legged stool right it took
myself as a teacher it took the students
and it took the parents to all work
together to make sure that education was
the best it could be and so
we were all part of that that stool this
is part of that the Senate has acted on
two legs of the stool already so we had
Senate Bill 140 which is the student
teaching stipend that went through the
Senate education and we're working with
them still on the possibility of a loan
repayment program that is going to be
one way to help reduce barriers of
people coming into profession so this we
see is that third leg of the stool if we
can't support the teachers and the
Educators coming into the profession
we're not going to be able to fill the
positions that we still have open across
the state and there's many positions
still open across the state so at this
point I'm going to turn it over to Irv
Richardson like I said our coordinator
of public education School support he's
going to share some more expertise on
the importance of supporting mentoring
programs for early Educators thank you
thank you Megan
good morning chairman Ladd and honorable
members of the House Education committee
my name is Megan cedis Irv Richardson
and I'm here representing Nea as the
coordinator of public education School
support I also speak from my experience
as a teacher and school principal
I'm here to testify in support of SB 218
which establishes an early educator
professional development Grant
this bill would require that as part of
their District professional development
plans districts would be required to one
articulate what are the professional
learning goals and descriptions of the
activities that districts will use to
orient support and Mentor Educators who
are one or more of the following and I
think this is important within the first
three years of the profession Megan
alluded to the fact that ingersoll's
research shows that people leave within
the first half that all Educators leave
within the first five years
it's also people who are in there
working in a new school or District so I
know people who've had experience
teaching in one District go to another
District they also need support although
it's a different kind of support
and then people within districts are
switching roles those people would also
get support and I'd like to point out
that this bill appropriately uses the
word educator New Hampshire regulation
50102s defines Educators as
administrators educational Specialists
instructional Specialists teachers para
Educators educational interpreters and
School nurses this means that when
passed this bill would help to ensure
that in addition to supporting new
teachers which is incredibly important
districts would also be designing and
providing support to new administrators
educational Specialists instructional
Specialists para educators
interpreters and School nurses and I
know at least three former
administrators in the room and I know
when I started I felt prepared when we
graduated from Southern Maine but I
could have used some additional support
in those first few years
so this would allow districts to access
funds to support the professional
development activities in which the
district's new Educators would be
engaged and I think this is actually as
it should be because when it comes to
working with our students there are no
unimportant jobs and that Educators
assuming these roles need and deserve
support as they learn their new
responsibilities and refine their
professional skills
as Megan alluded to concerns about
educated Recruitment and Retention are
not new
long before the current shortage of
Educators research informed us that up
to half of all new teachers were leaving
the profession the first five years this
turnover costs districts as they have to
spend time and resources recruiting new
teachers and supporting new teachers it
also costs the students because of new
teachers coming in who don't know the
routines and don't know the school
culture
research has shown that strong and
effective support and mentoring programs
have the following benefits
one it helps in recruiting new Educators
schools and districts with mentoring
programs are more likely to attract new
Educators because these Educators know
they will be joining an organization
that offers them support and
encouragement
it advances the professional learning of
new Educators by working with an
experienced high quality Mentor in the
school or District new Educators
increase their professional skills more
quickly than by using trial and error in
isolation experienced Educators serving
as coaches and mentors can increase new
Educators learning this is particularly
important with some of the site-based
plans which people don't go through
preparation but they go on site and have
only a mentor to help them develop their
skills
it reduces educator attrition Educators
who feel supported engaged in their
schools professional culture and who are
making a positive difference in their
students lives are more likely to stay
in the profession
this bill shows the legislators
intentions to support the new Educators
in New Hampshire
and finally it increases staff
collaboration and reduces isolation with
orientation and mentoring Educators
develop social capital and create a
sense of collective efficacy in a
positive School culture there's research
that shows that student achievement is
higher in schools with greater social
capital and educator collaboration
once this bill becomes law there are
organizations in New Hampshire ready to
support schools and districts as they
work to orient support and Mentor new
educators
the New Hampshire educator Effectiveness
for Student Success a Statewide group
collaborating with Consultants from the
chief State School officers and the
University of Florida Ceta project is
working on developing mentoring
resources that will soon be available
our organization Nea New Hampshire
provides Mentor training to local
affiliates that request it at no cost
and our next one is coming up in
Haverhill on June 26th if anyone would
like to attend Haverhill New Hampshire
yes
yeah I don't think Massachusetts would
be good with us going over the border to
provide training although it could
happen so District support for new
educators will be partially supported
through the funds of this bill
and was brought up earlier These funds
can supplement a District's use of Title
II funds currently the New Hampshire
Department of Education does contract
with a group in Fort Collins Colorado
for about 469 thousand dollars to
provide mentoring for Rural teachers and
that's great but
it would not that work does not provide
support to the other Educators that
would be covered with this bill
as president Tuttle indicated in her
testimony this legislation would provide
additional support to New Hampshire
Educators in a time when we are
experiencing shortages and a great need
for additional highly qualified
Educators I urge this committee to find
that SB 218 ought to pass thank you and
any questions thank you very much any
questions representative thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
could you review for the committee what
is the content of your Mentor training
there are several different components
to the mentor training the first one
really is looking at a way of being and
making sure that our goal for the new
Mentor isn't to create a clone of myself
but to support you and your learning as
an individual educator
then we get into how do we give and
accept feedback so we often I was taught
as an administrator to spend a lot of
time here's how you give feedback we've
learned that it's also important to help
the new educator understand how do I
receive accept and use feedback then we
get into an instructional conversation
so how can I sit down and help you plan
a better lesson how can I help you
reflect upon your lesson and how can we
work together on improving the school
culture
yeah so you also mentioned the issue of
the five-year
window
is is it your feeling that many leave
the profession because of the isolation
in their own classroom without the kind
of administrative or peer support
that's what the research would indicate
I think there are different reasons why
people leave but
Dan lordy talked about we used to work
in individual one-room School houses and
then now it was like an egg crate where
we put all the individual legs but we
really don't interact and support each
other as much as we could so it's not
every educator that's leading because of
isolation but it is a strong factor in
why some people even thank you
further questions from the committee
yes represent dry and then
representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question is there any priority
as to how this would be awarded among
school districts
that I don't know of a priority it would
be those when they
amended their professional development
plans to include this would include what
funds would match their Title II funds
so I know of no
we're going to serve this group first
okay
um
so there's there's no
um like Financial priorities or rural
priorities or anything like that no
yeah as far as I know yes thank you
can you explain to me better exactly
what this money specifically is being
used for is it to pay the mentors extra
or what is it I'm not sure I understand
it could be one of several things it
could be to pay a mentor for a new
educator or it could be that someone
needs a class in classroom management or
they need to attend workshops so we're
leaving that up to the local districts
to determine okay we Megan is a new
principal or a new teacher or a new
paraprofessional what does she need for
support
and then we could use these funds to
provide her with that support if it's a
mentor great if it's a workshop great
thank you support representative Heath
I just have to say thank you
um
many years ago when I was an assistant
superintendent we ran a mentoring
program in the sau19 and the results
were so
fabulous not only did the collegiality
amongst in between teachers
administrators and parents but the
children benefited completely children
had higher assessment scores they did
better in classrooms everybody was
happier
um do you anticipate those kinds of
findings if we have this Grant and quite
frankly
um as a person on division two in
finance I look forward to working with
you on this so hopefully this passes
this body
thank you
thank you for the question coming I I do
anticipate those results coming out of
this when I first started teaching in
Keene years ago I I had a mentor as a
new teacher but then when I moved
districts and was teaching in Pembroke I
was you know 10 years into my teaching
profession but I had a mentor more for
the culture of the school and both of
those instances made an enormous
difference and how I felt as a teacher
and just everything you would just
mention so I do think those results will
come out of this
further questions from the committee
thank you very much and Herb what I
would do if Megan want to get a degree
in principleship or Administration
Center of Southern Maine
Charlie Smith yeah that's right I
remember thank you
good morning my name is Sue Hannah and I
live in Derry I am an educator in the
Manchester school district and I am the
President of the Manchester Education
Association
I wanted to speak about this bill today
because I think it's extremely important
if I'm not one of the few then I'm
probably the only person in the state
who actually has a job that addresses
this I am not a mentor for the
Manchester School District we don't have
any
when I first started teaching in
Manchester in 2005 we did have a mentor
program
it was fantastic it helped me feel at
home immediately it helped me to
understand the evaluation process it
helps me to
know that I had someone who had my back
and if I had any questions about what I
was doing I knew that I had a person
that I could ask
uh Manchester lost that program in the
2011-12 school year when there was a lot
of financial Devastation going on there
um
right now what I do is I work for the
Manchester School District on
professional development and
credentialing
I work with the new teachers who are
coming in Manchester had over 100 new
teachers come in this year
about 50 of them
are not credentialed
and that's what I'm working on with them
plus I'm working with another at least
70 people who are searching for a
different credential so it's a lot of
work and it's a lot of time having
mentors in the schools and in the school
district would be extremely important to
be able to help these people understand
the Myriad of paperwork that you need to
go through in order to get a credential
if you're not going through the
traditional route of college
um but it's also really important for
the district to be able to address all
the competencies that the Department of
Education is looking for in an educator
and that the district would be looking
for in an educator
our school district in particular is is
working so hard
to do these things but without mentors
these people are not
able to be supported in the way that
they need to be and so I know we will be
losing some of these brand new Educators
who are really excited about coming in
and working with students
and improving the school district
but because of the the lack of mentors
we are not able to completely support
them you know there are 1100 School
Educators in our district there's a lot
that needs to go on
and so from the largest District in the
state it's really important to have a
program like this
even if it's one person at the
elementary level and one person at the
secondary level it's better than nothing
because we have someone we know we can
rely on to go out and help people in
their day-to-day and not feel like as Dr
Richardson said that they're in an egg
crate and they can't go talk to each
other
when I had a mentor when I first started
in Manchester
I knew I had someone to talk to
and I knew that
I had people around me who were in the
same boat that I was and coming in at
the same time and we found a lot of
I would like to
ask that you approve this bill and
support it it is really really important
to
the retention of great educators
you don't know what you have until
you're probably three or four years in
as far as a new educator and what they
can do
but if they're going to leave us in
those first three to five years we will
never know what we had and what our
children will miss out on
thank you thank you very much are there
questions from the committee
representative
yes thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question thank you for coming
in I'm assuming you're on school
vacation yes indeed
I'm confused about
the concept of mentoring
I've always thought of that as something
that comes about naturally and Affinity
between people you know someone who's
new looking up seeking out somebody with
greater Authority and experience so I'm
curious it sounds to me like you're
creating a position of a mentor or are
you talking about training current
Educators and how to be mentors
the answer is yes
so
mentoring educators
being able to have some positions in the
school district where we have
experienced Educators who can work with
a group so we have a large group of
Educators in the room today if I were
going to work with all of them
teach them about what our evaluation
system is like teach them about those
first days of school and what to do or
maybe what not to do I would be able to
teach them about
the the policies and so on of the
district so mentors can take on a few
different roles in a school district
because mentoring on the large scale
which is what we're talking about here
would be helping our newer Educators
providing workshops for them on maybe a
monthly basis to say okay it's time to
get ready for grades here's how you do
report cards here's how you use your
student information system
on a smaller basis we also have mentors
who are working with
individuals on their
credentialing plans and that is if I'm a
mentor I'm an educated experienced
educator
I have a certification of K-8 Elementary
Ed so if I'm working with another
educator who is getting that
certification I can mentor them I can
work with them on what they're doing in
their classroom have them observe me I
go observe them we work on their
paperwork to get credentialed and make
sure they're taking the proper either
classes or workshops or whatever it
might be to get them to that point of
being a credentialed educator so we have
a number of different opportunities for
what Mentor can be in this case we're
talking more on the broad perspective of
being able to work with many Educators
at once I
going through an orientation process
before the school year starts and being
able to provide
some support and some leadership that
our people especially those who
I have never done anything with teaching
go ahead
thank you it seems to me
um
teachers would be natural mentors
because there we are kind of mentoring
in the classroom all day long so it it
and am I understanding correctly that
sounds like we would be teaching
educating teachers and how to reach
outside of their classroom and consider
mentoring and teaching their colleagues
in order to build a better school for
everybody involved correct so as an
experienced educator
I'll give you my last last year when I
was actually in the classroom
um
I worked with the educator next door who
was new to teaching she is on an
alternative certification plan
um she's teaching math and I'm teaching
literacy so completely different however
I'm in her classroom all the time or
she's coming into mind to see what I do
we work together we created Escape rooms
and all kinds of things for all of our
students together and using both the
math and the literacy
but what I was doing was mentoring her
making sure that she had a good
understanding of what's expected in the
classroom
and yes as Educators we do that but
for where I am I can't really go beyond
right there
I didn't have someone teaching a class
on the other side of me or I probably
would have helped them too but this is a
bigger perspective this is uh either at
the the school level or at the district
level where they're talking about things
that the educator needs to know and
understand things like policies and uh
the the ethics and conduct policies of
the doe we're talking a a broader
perspective of what's expected for
writing lesson plans for creating unit
plans for following the the curriculum
as it's been adopted and so
understanding those kinds of things it's
a lot for someone coming in especially
who's never been an educator to have a
giant program like amplify or I ready or
something like that plopped in front of
them and say go to it right if we don't
support them in that and we can do that
as mentors with multiple people so I as
a mentor maybe for literacy can take
anyone and everyone k through eight who
is going to be teaching the amplify
program and be able to train them all my
Educators right now in Manchester are
trained for that
but next year when we get new people
who's going to have time to train them
because it's a big program and the
educators are like okay I have to go do
this and pay attention to what I'm doing
with my class it's really hard to be
able to make sure the the person
down the hall is doing the same thing
because we're not right next to each
other right so that's what it's about
representative cascadden thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question
um so I've written a mentoring program
handbook and I got a little confused
with something that you said so I want
to see if we can clarify it
is it the intent and I you have such a
large District to add a full-time
benefited position as a mentor or from
my experiences it
um
a stipended position for a teacher who's
working in the field
and because mentoring requires time over
their required day that there would be a
stipend for them to provide that support
and mentoring so I'm not sure which
you're talking about thanks so I I I
don't know that that's defined
necessarily in this bill but I think
it's something that
um depending on what happens here and
how it goes forward maybe districts
would be able to develop either way
I have been in a district where we had
mentors for the whole District
and they that was their only job they
went from school to school and we have
21 schools in Manchester so they were
all over the place working with all
these new people making sure that they
were being taken care of appropriately
we also at the time had mentors in our
schools so each school had its own
Mentor who could talk about what's going
on in the school right what's expected
in the school so I think it really
depends on the district as far as how
that would work if you have a district
that has three schools it's going to be
a lot different than
Manchester with 21.
follow-up
um it would seem though that with the
amount of money we're talking about here
that it really applies more to a
stipended position
than a totally new position that
includes benefits but just right I I and
again I think it's because it's titled
to money entitled too tied yeah and all
of that it really depends on the
district because
because of the district sizes they're
going to get a different amount of Title
II money so some students could use it
as per school and some schools school
districts can use it as per District so
they could talk yeah because stipending
21 people might be just as much as
you're welcome representative Tanner
thank you
um and thank you for taking my question
uh I was sitting here trying to remember
way back when
um as a as a person coming out of a you
know a bachelor's degree in a master's
degree coming into a school district as
a what behind the ear teacher and
um the things that you've been saying
about the mentoring and about the
culture and the program I think are
important but you know uh they don't
teach you and and it's kind of like
being a parent there's no textbook that
tells you how to parent and how to react
to kids
um how to how to discipline kids how to
realize that there are all different
types of kids
um
and how to handle situations when they
pop up that you least expect you know
um even in student teaching I remember
that you know how how difficult it was
would you go back to the dorm and talk
about
the little boy that fell in the toilet
or something and you know how how that
just was such a you know big surprise
and how do you deal with it all of a
sudden and at least student teaching you
had a you had a master teacher that was
there to help you through it right
when you go out on your own you don't
and I'm just wondering if you could kind
of talk a little bit about that side of
mentoring about how important it is to
have
an experienced teacher uh to get you
through those rough spots the first
couple of years
thank you I appreciate that question I
the having an experienced educator
working with someone who's Brand New
is incredibly important because as you
said there's a lot of things that aren't
necessarily going to be in a textbook or
something that you learn in a college
classroom and so everybody's learning it
even those people who didn't get a
degree in teaching and I think that
that's really important to understand
educators
are lifelong Learners and we've we
always do rely on each other for a lot
of things
having an experienced educator when
again when I came to Manchester I
already had 11 years experience at
Merrimack Valley
so coming in I knew what I was doing for
teaching but I didn't know about
Manchester I didn't know about the the
culture of the city I did not know about
the culture of the building I was in
having
an experienced educator
who knew Manchester for me who could say
these are the things that you need to do
or not do
knowing that I could call him at any
time and say this happened right
um
did I do the right thing
to be able to be coached to say
yes you did the right thing but let's
talk about it right how else could you
have what else could you have done if
this situation presented itself again
how how might you react differently
I I think it's very important and you
know the process
that we see in business of onboarding
and bringing people into work in a place
you get trained
my daughter right now is a traveling
nurse in Washington state she has had
before she even got there
last week
she had at least a month's worth of
training online
had a training yesterday not even in the
hospital she's going to be in and is
doing a couple more days of training
before she sees a patient
um we don't have those kinds of things
we don't even have that kind of time
in education so to be able to have
somebody who is
specifically trained to make sure that
as people are coming in and are starting
a school year are completing first
semester
are working on creating assessments
working on how can I
add to this curriculum how can I
do something exciting for my students
how can I differentiate my instruction
all of that really needs to have a
mentor for these Educators who are
coming in because they either don't know
enough about teaching or they don't know
anything about teaching and and are
quite often stuck with well what do I do
right now because I don't know how to do
this for Behavior or I don't know how to
do this for for what this is expecting
there are so many changes that go
through uh in from the doe down to the
districts and and how we're doing things
and how we're improving our education
for the Educators in particular I think
it's really important to know that
having someone to guide you through it
just like a trainer in business just
like your professor in a college
classroom you need to have somebody who
is there to be able to help you
especially to reflect on what you've
been doing just an evaluation from your
your principal or your administrator is
not enough it doesn't come sometimes in
time
to be able to
change how an educator would react in a
situation
if if the
evaluation is like in November right we
don't know if something happens in
September or October that person needs
to have somebody to go to to be able to
talk it out to reflect on it and figure
out how to be a better educator or that
what they did was great and let's move
on
thank you any further questions from the
committee
thank you very much thank you
so I have no further pink cards on this
I'm going to close this hearing on 218.
and with that uh we are going to go into
caucuses and we'll be caucusing for a
brief time here uh we do caucus in this
room so folks that means everybody has
um
no it's awesome I'm glad we had a
problem
we're going to be uh coxing for about 15
minutes
too
okay
1.3 million dollars that's it holy cow
so the 1.3 million dollars they would
have to completely expend their their
own applications
would have to be completely spent at
first
so they would have to completely spend
yeah
foreign
we have several bills here on the docket
for today we're going to go ahead with
our executive session uh uh 266 as I
mentioned prior to uh
this is a bill that came in dealing with
improvement in our Assessment program
and it's a bill it's just totally
rewriting 193 e
two three whole nine yards it's dealing
with adequacy and uh we're working with
doe on it
um it's not going to be exact today uh
much more work has to be done on this
particular Bill we've had I don't know
how many work sessions which been full
day work sessions on this bill
and it's like 40 pages in length
and so with that we're going to jump
over 266 and not have well I'm going to
open it up and then we'll recess this to
another time because there's several
things I want to share right now so
we're going to open up SB 266 relative
to the Statewide education Improvement
Assessment program
so what I have here I spent the weekend
trying to filter through some of the
discussion we've had representative
cascaden it was not easy
um I'm gonna pass one of these out to
I also of course talked with Caitlin
over at Doe and and Dr Green and there's
the reason why this bill is put forward
is that we are putting forward in Fall
the Essa Grant application to the
federal government and there's some
things within these chapters of law
which need to be changed tweaked in
order to facilitate the application
which will be forwarded however in doing
so 266 changed a whole lot the delivery
of an adequate education the criteria
Etc and we're not prepared to do that
and until we really have a understanding
what we're clearly doing with this
section of law
so I'm handing this out I'm not going to
go through it but you can see some areas
which are underlined
I only went through about page 30 of it
and then gave up
and um
I want to hand it out to you so that you
can look at it as well we're going to
have to have another
work session on this one of the things
we can do with this bill we can retain
it and work on it or we can modify part
of it to support what we need to do with
our Federal Grant
and then deal with a new bill coming in
if we're going to have to do that in
November
see what you think we will set up in the
calendar another work session 4266.
so I'm going to recess this to a time to
be announced yes representative cascaden
just a question my concern was the fact
that both the ibass and the pbas were
required now
um so I agree with you that I would want
more clarification on that piece because
at one point it was they had a choice
of D either one or the other yeah and
then when Pace was canceled now we've
got to do both the performance is a lot
of work in prepping that's right and
those come two components you just
mentioned aren't in this that's where I
stopped it's yeah it's complicated
thanks it's very complicated
yes
thank you I just want to ask for
clarification so are the underlined
Parts reflective of
the changes the committee was discussing
as we did and current law
say again please and current law thank
you
there are a number of sections which
were just like all the indicators for
inadequate delivery of an adequate
education were left out
of 266.
and that that's that's a lot of
legislation
so that would be in the subsequent Pages
we got it uh side by side from Jennifer
4 would that that all noted
that information she had there is not
yet been placed into this
so it's it's a huge bill you know how
we've addressed adequacy in Prior years
and we've looked at several components
like the criteria the content of an
adequate education
that took an act of Congress to get the
bill out of here and so changing the
whole adequacy law
is huge and I right at this time I don't
think we're ready to do it
that's my my position
so we'll have a work session on that
we'll recess until a time to be
determined
for today is 213 relative to education
institution policies on social media we
had a subcommittee on that and there's
not a clear recommendation that came out
of the subcommittee
so without that recommendation I'm not
prepared to take any action on this
until we can have a committee of a whole
and work on this bill and try to come
out with a recommendation that's going
to be something that we can
move or at least discuss here I'm seeing
some separate amendments coming out
right now there's a Waters Amendment
there's a McDonald Amendment there's a
belcher Amendment
um
and one of those amendments I saw the
first time this morning and I'm not
satisfied with that I want to see all
amendments coming out of the
subcommittee with everybody having an
opportunity to really discuss it and
know what they're doing
so again I will recess this bill until a
time to be determined
this is establishing An Early Education
professional development Grant which we
discussed earlier this morning
I am also going to recess this until
there's several suggestions for amending
language which I will discuss with the
committee one of our representative
cascad and you are missing change and or
at one point that might be a
consideration we want to look at
but without that Amendment if we put we
we don't have it in front of us so I
would like to I'm not saying this bill
is not worthy not at all but there may
be some areas which we have to look at
in terms of getting it ready for so this
too will be held next week because this
is an early bill
time to be announced so that takes us
down to 272 establishing a parent's Bill
of Rights and education we know how this
is going to end up so I've asked that
the emotion come forward and represent
cordial I'm looking for a motion from
you
on SB 272 I move ought to pass
so we have a motion made by represent
cordiello and second by represent
Belcher on SB 272 establishing a parent
parents Bill of Rights and education
for Senate courtiello and we're going to
have one person voting for each side on
this bill as we've mentioned speaking
speaking yes
one thing that was brought up at the
hearing I remember was um
a senator suggested and I I think this
is the case that when parents start
asking questions on the issues that are
really the primary
focus of this bill has been on a small
part of it
having to do with gender identity issues
and uh
when parents start asking these
questions they already
probably have a feeling that the
suspicion that there's something to ask
about they're just not going to go
um
you know it's it's not calling out a
certain group of people I I believe
it is not I believe outing a particular
group of people
all this bill asks for is truthful
answers
to parents questions and I believe that
facilitates a partnership or in an
earlier hearing if you are here
there was uh because Megan Tuttle on a
different Bill brought up a phrase I've
heard before the three-legged stool
parents teachers students
I believe that this bill
supports that idea
it it forms a partnership
based on truth what this bill
prohibits
is something that has been part of law
since the very beginning of us having
laws you shall not lie
it also supports something else that is
a pillar of our society which is
parental rights parental authority over
one of the counter arguments that came
up again and again and there was as we
all know on this committee a waterfall
an avalanche whatever metaphor you want
to use the number of emails we got on
this were over was overwhelming and one
of the issues that was brought up was
and that could happen yes but there are
already laws that would make an
withholding this information so there's
an exception
but another point I want to bring out is
that something that I don't think was
maybe mentioned um
let's realize that also there can be
abuse by school personnel
and I could cite a number of articles I
read lately things that were sent in
those emails but I want to keep this as
brief as possible I may go over my usual
rule of talking for three minutes
because this is a very important bill
and very complex
um actually it's not complex as I said
it is you shall not lie
um
so we have to recognize also that school
Personnel abuse can be a potential issue
too
as I said this bill upholds parental
Authority there has been a century I
won't go into detail here Supreme Court
precedence for over a century have
upheld parental rights
Meyer versus Nebraska peers Versus
Society sisters Wisconsin versus Yoder I
could go on and on okay I have a lot
and there's a reason that the parental
Authority is upheld time and time again
I ran for this office
because I used to be a teacher and I
taught about dystopian literature
and I started to see that some of it
was starting to come true a bit and one
of the novels is brave new worlds that I
taught and it is a a novel about a
society in which there are no parents
and it is a societies that is based on
lies and I fear that not to be dramatic
this is kind of a step in that direction
um
some of the testimony that was
particularly moving for me and I was the
clerk so I was like along with
representative dry who took over because
it was a lot of writing and I found some
of the most dramatic testimony to be
from
people who used to live in communist
countries and in those countries
parental rights are not encouraged or
outlawed pretty much and
parental rights and these societies are
also based on withholding truth so just
I I know I'm I'm talking more than I
usually would but um this is very
important
um as a teacher I used to really go to
the text
I think the uh you know it's a list of
of Rights it kind of brings all together
the different laws from all over our
statutes for parents but the ones that
are contentious are
uh let's see
um it's towards the end the ones you
know this is the part that that has been
very contentious
so parents have the right to inquire of
the school or School personnel
and to be truthfully and completely
informed
about three different issues regarding
gender identity this phrase is repeated
three times so I'm going to repeat it
again
the right to inquire not the right of
school officials to out students this is
the right of the parent to ask a
question the right to inquire of the
school or School personnel and be
truthfully and completely informed
three times that's repeated infringement
of the rights in this bill if you go a
little earlier
there's a similar repetition
infringement for the purposes of this
chapter shall include
The Knowing withholding of truthful
information that's one phrase and then
the next line The Knowing provision of
misleading
and then the the line right after that
is the denial of the existence of
information what do all these phrases
have in common
so I this bill
ought to pass and it must pass because
our society is based on these two these
pillars of Parental Authority
and truth without them
not only will the three-legged stool
collapse but so will our society
thank you
thank you uh represent Tanner
thank you there's no heavily heavier
burden than a great potential here
um SB 272 we know is part of a national
political movement to disrupt dismantle
and defame teachers in our Public
Schools
parents are being led into believing
that they are being lied to denied
rights and mistreated by teachers in our
schools
parents already have and will continue
and we all respect
their rights to direct the care and the
education of their minor children
and there's a technical advisory
document available on the New Hampshire
Department of Education website
speaking to student privacy and student
transparency laws
that outlines the roughly 20 to 30
rights parents currently have concerning
privacy and school transparency
parents are also protected by a federal
FERPA laws as well as these state laws
and have many educational opportunities
available to them
schools and teachers accept their
responsibilities to educate students
to help them grow and learn
to keep them as safe as possible to
nourish self-esteem
to challenge all students to be better
than they think they can be and to
assist them in becoming good citizens
helping a student might mean providing
snacks or tissue to wipe a tear
or tending with a Band-Aid to a bumper
bruise
offering Consul consolation uh for the
loss of a pet or a loved one or to
literally put themselves in the line of
fire to save their students lives which
we see on a daily basis
teachers and counselors provide a
trusted adult to both parents and
students allowing them to vent
to grieve to celebrate successes to find
resources for problem solving to hear
words of encouragement
and to tell their students that they're
Pride proud of them
SB 272
is a bill that cynically sows distrust
and Division and as a consequence hurts
children
especially children who are lgbtq nine
Bond nine binary or transgender
or their families
it is a bill that forces schools that
could be the safe place
for vulnerable kids into a perilous
place by requiring schools to notify
parents of their child's participation
in clubs activities or organizations
this means groups like gay straight
Alliance or alatine
in which anonymity is important for
their participation and without that
those groups cannot function
SB 272 also requires teachers and
schools to report students who request
to be known by a nickname or want to be
addressed by a transgender name or
pronoun
at times this rush to inform will deny
the time for thoughtfulness and care
that is sometimes needed for a teen and
their family to approach this sensitive
issue
many of us are facing challenging and
thought-provoking issues as part of our
daily lives
schools teachers and families need to
support each other and work together as
they help children navigate the
complexities of growing up
legislators should use child welfare and
the best interests of the child as the
focus of their efforts but SB 272 does
not support children and is not in the
best interest of children
rather this ultra-conservative National
agenda item is intended to incite fear
stoke the fires of division Among Us and
create an adversarial battle between our
Public Schools teachers and Families
this is not the New Hampshire way and we
should not become part of an attempt to
marginalize vulnerable children who are
already struggling
I I oppose this bill and oppose the fact
that it singles out
um again vulnerable transgender uh lgbtq
children thank you thank you very much
okay we've heard it from both uh
positions now so we're ready to go ahead
and
the emotion on the floor is OTP
that motionless made by represent
cordial and second by represent Belcher
uh Madam clerk would you please call the
roll
representative Ford yes
representative McDonald yes
representative blackis yes
representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative of course yellow yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Ellison yeah representative Murray no
representative Heath no representative
Balboni no Representative cascadin no
representative Damon no represent uh
chairman Ladd yes
10 years 10 days
yes representative miler I'd like to
move to itl 272 thank you and second by
representative Tanner yes I'd like to
second that I think okay we have motion
on the table itl uh 272 made by
representative Miler and second by
representative Tanner
discussion from the maker of the motion
welcome second
okay we have a motion on the table Madam
clerk would you please call the rolls
representative Ford no
representative McDonald no
representative Lucas no
representative Belcher no representative
dry no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no
representative Peter now no
representative course yellow no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes representative Murray yes
representative Heath yes representative
yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad no
10 years 10 years
okay so
um the it'll go on the floor as with no
recommendation and the auto pass motion
will be brought up first who's going to
write The Minority Report represent
the itl report
thank you
okay with that uh We've concluded uh our
action today on SB 272 and that does
conclude our meeting this morning with
House Education thank you very much
we're done uh representative yes before
we leave I'd like to thank the teachers
in the audience who have taken part of
their holiday uh this week to come in
and have a chance we don't usually have
a chance to see practicing teachers in
the audience for the education committee
so on behalf of the committee I'd like
to thank you for being here and being
well everybody enjoy the sun while it's
out
no I want to contact the people over at